hey sis come on up how you doing good to
see you
goodness yeah listen not as good as you
song of the year A B C D E F yes yes yes
so I can't believe I'm here wow I mean
okay you get the call First Time nominee
you get the call I mean the song took us
all I mean you know we are all swept up
in the wave of it but you get to call
your nominator for a Grammy what is that
moment like for you I saw it on the live
stream and then I didn't realize that
they were probably gonna announce things
in alphabetical order so last thing I
was thinking about was really like them
actually sang My Song and then very at
least then saying my song first with
song of the year so I didn't even I was
like it'd be really funny if I like lost
so I'm gonna film it and then I didn't
even have time to set my phone down and
then they said the song and I I
instantly just started bawling crying
and my band mates were with me and we're
actually we're in Spain and so normally
it announced for 11 o'clock and it was
announcing at 6 00 PM for me and it was
the worst day ever I was just pacing
around and I didn't think I was going to
get nominated but then all of these
articles kept coming out predicting me
for different things and then some
articles said I wasn't able to be
nominated that I didn't know and then
now I'm here and it's you're here and
then on top of all of that Joy then you
then Taylor Swift says when I heard this
song I was like holy cow I need to call
her up I mean I just saw the look on
your face I can see in your eyes you're
like what the hell is my life God this
here's been so insane I also recently
just confirmed the fact that I'm going
on the Pink tour as well this year so go
on tour it was such incredible icons
Taylor Swift and pink and they're taking
this me on their Stadium tours it's
absolutely ridiculous that I'm so
honored to be a part of and I've
actually been going to the gym for once
in my life trying to like yes pink is no
joke baby that body is no joke I can't
even do a pull-up like I have to learn
how to do pull-up or something like how
does how did this happen she's gonna
have you at like in acrobatics swinging
through the air doing all her I hope she
lets me borrow her props you know like
I'll be in the sky with her or something
like that it'll be fun but first you are
going to open up for Taylor Swift on
this massive tour that everybody has
been trying to get tickets for knowing
how in demand this tour is going to be
what is that gosh I mean I already knew
this tour was going to be huge but then
just seeing everything happen it's been
so incredible and I'm in no way surprise
and I'm just so honored that Taylor
worked years and for years and years
effortlessly trying to like make this
career for herself and she did that and
she built her career over such a over
the past 10 years and now she can fill
out these stadiums and she just put me
on the stage in front of her fans that
she worked for years and years and years
to get and the fact that she's just
letting me girl power baby is paying him
oh gosh and the fact that she's putting
me in front of her fans that she worked
so hard to get and she just is letting
me walk on that stage is such an honor
and I'm just I'm so excited I've been
practicing guitar and bass and the fact
that Paramore's on the tour Gracie
Abrams is on the tour be but do behind
Phoebe Bridgers Owen like girl in red oh
Muna like oh everybody's just so
incredible yeah absolutely what kind of
conversations have you had with her
about the tour and like or have you had
any conversation it's about what the
expectation I mean we're just talking
about how excited we are I asked if it
was cool to bring my band and she was
like yeah and yeah I mean she was even
talking about how incredible the guitar
players are on this tour like all of the
women can really shred it really made me
feel like I gotta practice my guitar
quite a bit you know but it definitely
it's it's just we're talking about how
excited it is and towards just so soon
it's going to be coming up so soon now
I'm gonna ask about the look because
it's a little like BDSM yes that was the
goal I just turned 18 and I um I've been
dressing like I've been eating I'm grown
now y'all I'm eight years I've been
acting like I'm still like dressing like
I was 18 but I was not but now I am and
now I can finally go to Ward shows
looking like something
foreign